so tell us a little bit about your
channel how long have you been on
YouTube and uh let us know what you've
been up to um so my channel is Audrey's
little farm and I teach about gardening
and raising chickens mostly for the
beginner chicken keeper beginner
Gardener um I do go a little bit more in
depth but majority of audience is
beginners for sure and um so I started
for the past two years I've been pretty
serious on YouTube I would say like in
the last year is when I've more dove
into um trying to grow the channel but I
started a Blog in 2018 and that became
my full-time income and then that's when
I started doing YouTube as well oh
that's amazing okay so you're still
doing the blog yep so that kind of is
running on autopilot right now and my
focus has been YouTube trying to learn
how to grow
that gotcha okay so
autopilot awesome um so fired up to have
you here and what is uh a question that
you have today um I think my biggest
thing that I w't help with on YouTube is
learning how to sell I feel like I sell
well but I don't sell often and I don't
really sell intentionally I brought up a
few stats just to give you like a
background so one of my main products is
a Zone 9B Gardening Guide which is the
zone that I live in and that's a huge
audience of mine because they talk a lot
about the Zone specific gardening and so
I have that guide and I pitched it the
very first time I think I pitched it on
YouTube was in January of 2022 and since
then um I pitch it here and there but it
mostly is just coming up in like Google
search results the same few videos and I
get a 5% conversion rate and I've made a
little under 8,000 in the last year on
that
guide and I was just looking Zone
nine Zone 9B but zone 9 gardening is
essentially the same but um like Florida
Texas Arizona California I'm in
California but I have people in all of
those states that follow me that will
that could use the
guide okay gotcha and so and the way you
get to it is shop how do you get to the
guide um if you're in my on my YouTube
channel so like you could do it from
right here on my shop but in the actual
videos that are about Z 9 I think on my
actual homepage I have a playlist that's
all about zone 9 so it's not in every
video it's just the ones related to zone
9 so on my actual home page uh so that
one right there would have it so that
very top link goes to the sales page and
so that sales page right now is
converting at
5% and that's just pretty much from
Google search people or you know I pitch
it casually in the videos but I'm not
really pitching the guide neily and so I
was just looking in July in July I
actually didn't even do one video I
don't think that mentioned the guide but
just from people finding me through
search um it was a 3.8 conversion rate
on that sales page and made a little
under
$500 yeah that's great and so the
question is how could we increase sales
and maybe even a little bit of the sales
communication and sales mindset is in
terms of incorporating that on YouTube
right I love it so I mean there a couple
things I think my first thought is um
mindset stuff as it pertains to sales
you know sales number one I think
there's like 1% of the population that
actually likes sales and typically
sounds like kind of a joke but typically
there's like something wrong with them
they're typically like narcissists or
they're something like you get into
psychology like the way their brain is
wired like the average person kind of
hates sales unless they're wired a
certain way so many people watching this
probably feel the same way I don't want
to be the use car salesman I don't want
to sell I just want to be creative and I
hope my stuff just sells so it actually
is I think very important that we invest
time even thinking of our e2e ratio in
consuming sales material that can help
shift our mindset
from compassionate people that we
resonate with that share similar
values I've done that over the years and
there's been there's been anchored mind
sets which I know we should talk about
tactics but it really does start with
our thinking that have helped me for
example to sell is to serve that
actually when we have a product that can
change someone's life get them better
results when you can connect I'm sure
the Zone uh 9B gardening materials to
how that's going to have people
literally be more fruitful if they're
going to sell produce like make more
money like it's an exchange of value
another mindset is your income is
directly correlated to the amount of
value you add to the marketplace and
when you have something value a sales
situation is simply exchanging something
for money in this case and what you give
them if it's more valuable than the
money that they give you then ultimately
it's a bigger win for the person that
you're serving and so if you can
position your your marketing and your
products even correlating it in sales to
kind of features and benefits we want to
have just unwavering confidence that we
should sell that it's our ethical duty
to sell because you have information
that other people don't know and they
need to know that information they could
even be more fruitful they can make more
money they can have more abundance and
so it then becomes adopting the mindset
of like it's my ethical responsibility
to figure out how to ethically persuade
the right people
because if they don't buy this pot
product it's either because it's they're
they don't even they're not in zone 9B
well you would never sell it to those
people they also don't want to take
action well great they shouldn't sell
that to them either but if they're at
all interested and you know that if they
don't just buy it but implement it it
will benefit them and that what they're
getting is worth more than the money
they're paying you I'm just trying to
kind of lay a foundation of some of the
mindsets in terms of why you should
perhaps even be louder about it and one
other interesting
um caveat would be you know if I even
the Bible's a big deal for me my faith
and I'm a Christian and so some people
think well you know but sales like would
that even be in the Bible would that
even be just kind of seems weird it
doesn't seem like the Christian thing to
do well it's actually completely a myth
it's actually sales is not just a good
idea it's a god idea there's a proverb
that says cursed is the person who
withholds grain which is interesting
that it's an agriculture illustration
when they have grain to meet someone's
need essentially so and it says sells
that curse is the person who doesn't
sell their grain as if we have something
that can benefit others and it doesn't
say that we should give it away it says
curse is the person who doesn't sell
grain to those in need and if you kind
of take that back you think about the
story of Joseph with with you know
people watching this whatever their
backgrounds of beliefs it's a very
powerful Old Testament story in Genesis
where for seven years Joseph stored up
grain and then when a famine hit it
doesn't say he gave it away there's a
lot of people in the world that are like
we should just give everything away
what's fascinating is he didn't give it
away he sold it and he first sold it for
money then he started trading it for
land and for livestock and this was a
god idea as a way of and he actually
saved a nation he saves Egypt couple
things one because he took seven years
to save up grain this makes me think
about all the Blood Sweat and Tears
you've put in to learn this master this
do this you probably aren't even
charging enough that would be as we
think about these mindsets that can help
us even think that it should probably be
more than $37 like it should probably be
$97 $197 you start thinking about what
is the value of what you have how can
you communicate the value of what you
have to the people that you're serving
and then have that boldness and that
confidence so those are a few things
that I think are fascinating even like
the biblical Theology of sales and then
finally um I think that the last thing
that can happen though is inevitably if
you get louder and if you get
Bolder there's still as soon as you
start to sell there's push back and
sometimes the fear we have is the more
we talk about on YouTube or the more we
talk about it on social media there's we
may experience less friction or negative
comments or whatever if we don't sell
something um and because there can be
some people that have the mentality that
like everything should be free or
whatever and so it this is why I think
it's so important that we develop the
mindset and belief system that Brick by
Brick on Truth ethics
Integrity allows us to have the
resilience to be okay with that like it
allows us to like not just get louder
get clearer not pushy but louder in your
videos more articulate and specific in
your videos about educating people and
pointing people to to this place where
you're make you're you're offering this
thing and then knowing ahead of time
though that typically the louder you get
the more push back you will get But
ultimately that just comes with the
territory and I like to have a a view of
empathy because even you know for
example you know you're a member of V we
give away a lot of free content but we
also charge for a course and
there's 5% of people that just are
really upset about that anyone who's
been in V sees the value of it and
there's the whole structure of money
back guarantee and all this other stuff
that we do just so we could be in
integrity and ethics but myself and the
entire think media team for sure we get
whether it's an email or comments and
it's never that many but it can feel
like a lot because if you like to be
liked and we're afraid of other people's
opinions or just sensitive to other
people's opinions I'm just like oh yeah
you know somebody send you an email like
how dare you charge for this you're like
because like Joseph I spent seven years
more than that Blood Sweat and Tears
learning this stuff testing this stuff
building this stuff I've made a program
that is more valuable for the around a,
which is our special offer right now
that V costs like I think about I'm like
why aren't you complaining about college
it costs $50,000 a year to go get a
digital marketing degree at a community
college right now not even a degree just
a year of classes
Americans spend $18,000 on
non-essentials why are you and it's
because of money mindsets typically but
all that to say is having the empathy um
for the push back you may get being okay
with that if you ultimately want to make
more sales now I want to talk about
tactic second but I love some feedback
any thoughts on money mindsets or sales
mindsets was any of that helpful in
regards to maybe how loud or how bold
you are in your videos about sales yeah
that was super helpful and I love the um
well the mindsets and then I also love
like the stories of the Bible because
that's like one of the reasons why I
love fallowing you too I love the
Christian or the shared Faith um and so
that was like really cool stories but um
I definitely think I could tell like as
you're talking to me that I'm like I
definitely don't sell enough because I'm
worried of like I don't want all my
videos to seem like a sales video so
then I rarely pitch it but when I do
pitch it it does well and so it's just
like like you were saying the more I
talk about it and the louder I get
you'll get pushed back but I would also
be way more
profitable I love it so let's talk a
little bit of tactics part to if you're
getting valued to and watching this
smash like and to be to give exact
chapter and verse proverbs 11:26 people
curse those who hoard grain but they
pray God's blessing on the one who is
willing to sell and so there's something
powerful um and uh a couple other things
you know when we pay we pay attention
and the transformation in the
transaction a lot of times we don't
value things that are free um we
download a lot of things that are free
and so we get when we invest in
something and that also could lead to
maybe more offers that you have um other
things that you develop that could be
connected to you raising your price
because if you think about you're an
ideal customer that maybe could learn
from all of the hard work and experience
and things you've learned and what
transformation you could ultim
um you know connect for them like some
people might think it' be outrageous to
to pay you
$10,000 to coach them but not really if
if it's at farmers markets or the way
that they sell produce or their Gardens
if you can then just say Well yeah if if
I actually walk people through that what
I know I could produce $20,000 of value
well then that would be an incredibly
Fair transaction more than fair they
would have doubled their investment if
you could if you could increase
someone's business or whatever it is um
by you could double it or triple it then
you start you know kind of reframing
some of those things the um tactics what
I would encourage is yes talk about it
more and there's a couple things there's
there's two things number one is
actually I learned this from shelene
Johnson it's funny as we're talking
about Audrey's little farm um is this
concept of actually called seeding
sometimes you don't have to sell like
overtly but you can do what's called
seeding and seeding would simply be like
not actually making an offer but talking
about your product a little bit more
like you may just say one of the things
that uh I talk about in my zone 9B
vegetable Gardening Guide is and you
talk about the importance of having a
planner or you talk about some of the
aspects of what's inside of that and I
would say that you could it's not always
like overt call to action Link in the
description or something like that but
and you probably notice me doing this or
perhaps maybe you do maybe don't but
maybe I'm talking about YouTube Secrets
like I don't I'm not saying go buy the
book but I'll hold the book up and I
might say you know one of the things
that I talk about in YouTube Secrets
second edition and so I see that this is
probably digital right your product is
digital yeah but you could printed out
like do you have a physical version yes
um I do so I printed it out and put it
in a binder so in all my videos that's
actually pretty much how I do it so I
don't say like all I'm talking about is
my guide I'll give you know like Zone
nine tips for March and then like I'll
give a few tips and be like but also in
my guide right here which is printed off
um you can see like the exact dates that
you need blah blah blah and so I do like
what you just did with the book I like
hold it up and then um and that seems
like that's why I think it sells good
just kind of on autopilot but obvious
but then I feel like um I feel like I
could probably actually do that with
other products I have in all my other
gardening videos that are
not I just kind of thought of that out
loud because I have a more in general
Gardening Guide that's for other
gardeners and um maybe like in my other
gardening videos I could do the same
similar thing are you also building an
email list yeah right now it's about
35,000 people how often do you email the
list uh usually every other day okay
great and so do you see a lot of sales
coming from email um yes trip wire sales
um like on a daily basis that's what so
people find me through YouTube and then
but mly through the blog and then that's
kind of just that I have some funnels
that are just in place so that's kind of
an evergreen autopilot thing but I do
like I'll physically email like real
broadcast sorry broadcasts every other
day but then I have my evergreen funnels
that they go through and value based
value based emails Broast yep um I do so
like right away they go to a trip wire
when they sign it from my email list and
that's where majority of sales come
through I would say like 70% of the
sales just go through like tripwire
sales right off the the bat when trip
wire that's trip wire would be a low
ticket offer before they bought anything
yep so they um I have them go to um uh
like they're free I have a chicken
keeping optin and a free planting
schedule for gardeners and so then the
chicken keeping people go to a trip wire
page for my ebook that's offered at $9
yeah which is that one that you have
pulled up and then um I have my
vegetable Gardening Guide that like in
general gardeners go to and that's I
think a or $1 13 offer at the trip wire
cost and then the Zone 9B guide is split
into just like the first chunk of it
which is which is just a planting
schedule not all of the tactics and that
sells for eight but they can upgrade for
19 at the are you when doing broadcast
emails are you making more offers in
email though um yes so I do a I try to
do a like actual flash sale to my email
list every other week cool and those do
pretty well and do you ALS do you do you
kind of use PS a lot
yeah I just started actually doing like
in every email now that I send a PS of
like ways that I can help and the first
two is like subscribe to YouTube that's
where I most active right now yes um
follow me on Instagram or head to my
shop and check out the digital products
I have which I also have a membership so
that's now been in my PS2 beautiful okay
I mean one to just want to acknowledge
like you're clearly uh a leader a
learner and doing so many best practices
and so that's really inspiring and this
General is one of the benefits of this
show is there's so much you can learn
coffee with canel family from the
execution uh here also I mean it would
seem you're making you're doing this
full-time under 10,000
subscribers yes um and you have the blog
as well yes so the blog last year um
what what this year let's see I think
last September is when I became
monetized so not quite a year but um
before that I was making affiliate
Revenue and product sales through
YouTube but just not very much but my
blog just all on its own was doing um a
full-time income so then that's when I
dove into
YouTube um and I guess that's been I
feel like I have a good General
understanding of sales and I do well at
it in my email marketing and on the blog
side but for YouTube I guess I've been
in that like weird mindset of trying to
grow it without selling too much because
I want the channel to grow but I've been
selling some so I guess what is the good
R should I be mentioning something in
every video or is there a ratio like
well I think so uh if then we then turn
our attention uh finally as we land the
plane
to YouTube um when was the last time you
made Zone 9B I know you have a whole
playlist but when was the last time you
made Zone 9B videos um in June so on if
you go to if you click on home of my
channel I have a like a whole um right
at the top I have that monthly Garing
tips and tasks and I started doing that
in February I guess I missed July
because we were out of town quite a bit
but um March April May June I did one
for each month and those are the last
ones I did specific to zone 9 what else
around Zone
9ine um and you're so zone 9 is the main
offer that is the deepest offer you have
for people basically um yeah so I have
um I just majority of my audience is
zone9 I have a um blog post on Google
that R ranks like top one to three
always on Google and that's how people
majority of people find me and so I
would say 80% of my audience is just
already Zone nine and so that's my main
offer as far as like what I'm trying to
pitch the most often which Mak sense
because I like talking about an area
where I actually know what I'm talking
about in um y i you know I don't have
any idea how to grow like in the middle
of Utah or Colorado somewhere where it's
cold so um I like talking about zone9
because it is specific to where I'm at
and
I just dove into that because that's
what's been the most successful for me
blog and now YouTube I'm in
California um okay Central Valley so
okay great great ranked second here with
the one month ago very great so um and
then did you give do you give a call to
action to Something free in this video
um I don't I think I only just bring up
the I show the guide I think at some
point um I'm trying to think which spot
it would be at but I tell at the end
like throughout the video I'll show like
the guide that I have and I kind of talk
a little bit about of it talk a little
bit about it and then at the end I think
I mentioned like you know the link to
this guide is in the description but I
don't call I don't think I call any
attention to a free guide okay so I mean
the other thing now that we've talked so
much about sales I I generally would
encourage that we don't really need to
sell on YouTube that the point of
YouTube would be to meet strangers meet
new people serve current subscribers um
and and connect with them in such a way
as to um uh you know build that
connection build no like and trust and
grow the channel and I'll give you then
one of my favorite Frameworks that would
be that I would uh do to just multiply
everything that you're doing and it
would be yeah not to sell on your videos
but to give away Something Free and my
favorite way way to actually do that
that can um affect the YouTube algorithm
and and serve the people that are
watching is I do the same thing I do
typically you you could still by the way
seed as you're doing you could still
seed the book because that's great to
from the time they meet you kind of seed
it but the problem with just even
alluding to our products is there does
come a point as you probably know in in
email marketing it's where it kind of
happens where like people in a way don't
know to buy until you clearly articulate
that like this is for sale and here's
how you buy it and a lot of times sales
is simply explaining what it is what the
process of checking out is ETC but
saying that here would be the framework
I love to um have videos that have
points and it seems like with your
chapters here you have the same thing
like you've got five tips and what I
love to do is create an
irresistible lead magnet they' be called
that would be the free gift one question
would be you already have some but is
there something that people would love
that you could give away for free that
people would just they would love to pay
money for and they would love to take
action on that would very specifically
like do you have a zone 9 lead magnet I
do so um the in it's very similar so
it's a free planting schedule which like
gives the date perfect great answer so
we have that already so so then what I
would do is in the video I would um let
me come back to why I would put the call
to action of that in the middle and then
why at the end exactly what you're doing
here like you're serving both YouTube
and building your email list and then
hopefully growing sales and growing your
channel so at the end of the
video we'll break it down so perfect
video recipe big idea hook content
transition transition is get that call
to action to another video if you had
five points you have a great hook good
thumbnail title and everything in the
beginning Point number one point number
two point number three point number five
I would recommend actually basically
being another video rather than being a
point you explain it's a point you touch
on and you're like so Point number five
is and you already have these in your
library is such and such and such zone 9
gardening and actually if you want a
deep dive on that click or tap the
screen and I'll see you in the next one
when we transition at the end we want to
transition fast so that we can increase
watch time um um avoid people dropping
off have people binge videos have people
watch multiple videos of ours okay fine
so that's Point number five so rather
than potentially like going super deep
in point number five this was five tips
for veget you know then actually use
that as a transition Point like if it
was plant varieties that thrive if you
had a video on plant varieties that
thrive you're like you know some of the
biggest plant varieties that thrive are
strawberries garlic and lettuce but
actually there's 10 of them and if you
want to see my video on all 10 click or
tap the screen my name is Audrey see you
in the next one smash like peace and
then it's like over and they and then
it's just click on that card okay so
then mid video one of the points is
watering schedule right and so you're
like and so tip number three is you
really need to dial in your watering
schedule now I actually have a guide
that's totally free you could like you
know print it out if you want put it on
your refrigerator whatever I'll link to
that in the description actually has a
whole watery schedule but here's what it
is and so weaving in an
articulated paino or solution that is
your free thing into one of your points
mid video
and basically doing that every video is
would be my my dream of YouTube so then
fast forward if we kind of dial in the
fact that we are inviting people on our
email list but we're also doing it in
such a way not it's not General it's
very specific and if it's a zone 9
download then that's a very specific
thing you're going to attract those
people that either care or they don't
trying to do two things grow our email
list but also grow our YouTube channel
and I think that's the best way to do it
mid video brief call to action that is
connected to one of the points and your
free th is a solution to that end of the
video they either already downloaded it
and kept watching or if they left
they're not there anyways but the goal
would be to just incl increase that view
duration and then finally doing that a
thousand times you know or as many
videos as you're posting um because as
as we go to 20,000 Subs 50,000 subs and
you've got a 100 or 200 videos in your
library that people are constantly
watching then there's constant new
awareness of people joining your email
list which is the best place for sales
to take place because now
people have stepped over that line to
that next level of trust with you some
people just want to hang out on the
YouTube channel great as ad revenue and
all that stuff goes up and maybe some
lit they they'll want to go deeper but
the people that that join on the email
list and perhaps they end also end up
binging five of your videos and so then
it would just also be a matter of if you
use that kind of formula or
template and you
um and then you do it repeatedly with as
good of video ideas as possible
eventually like or imagine if that call
to action was in this video the 287,000
one right the eventually out of your
next 100 videos then you've got like was
there one in this two-year-old one of
any kind I mean yeah so that one was the
first one I ever pitch the guide in so
that's where I think most organic sales
come from I would say sales great and
I'm saying in this case I mean you could
you could pitch the guide but I'd be
saying pitch the free thing I guess it's
kind of the same difference because it
leads the same direction but that also
could be the next 10 20,000 signups
organically on the other side of some
great video topics um would PCH yeah
would you pitch like on the videos where
I can specifically bring up the guide
but I can also always pitch the free
planting schedule would you do both in
the same video no i' I'd mainly hit the
free thing right or i' mainly maybe seed
the guide not Pitch you know like like
do what you did hold it up this is what
I work from because it becomes this
iconic thing that clearly people begin
to see and recognize um but yeah
mainly uh being brief bright fun and
done in the video and and and and
holding it or teaching from it or
something you know it could be as simple
as like you know in the first SE of
YouTube success is courage I mean you
got a punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face like all I did
was seed it no more call to action than
that and then perhaps mid video uh you
know first C is courage you know the
second C is clarity now here's a couple
thoughts about getting clear in your
channel but if you actually want to
download a free Clarity guide there's a
link in the description down below you
could fill that out so anyways Clarity
would be and then putting that in the
middle but getting through the video
because you still want of course the
view average view duration and all of
that and so you're you're building your
business while also building your
YouTube channel yeah yep yep that's
super helpful so there would be no I
guess um because in all of my videos I
could always pitch one of my free sign
up guides so is that something that
should always be done or or is there a
point where you want them obviously to
get to the end and go to the next video
but clicking a link in the description
is not necessarily bad I mean it's
better to get them on your email list
than to keep watching there's that fine
line uh yeah like you know uh Kyle who I
know you know well is the producer of
think media and like our our dream and
our vision is I'm like we don't always
have to include it in some cases we just
said what's the purpose of this video
does it actually fit would probably be
the number one question does it do it
fit without being forced and we love to
make videos that maybe have no call to
action of course Except watch another
video at the end they lead to some other
video um but if it fits I think is a big
key and I would say that oftentimes it's
more of a it's more of an ongoing
conversation of to your point you deeply
care about your brand you care about
your audience you care about trust you
don't want I do think there is such a
thing as like over pitching or over
promotion but to me I just like to crank
up the value as high as possible like
the value is so high the pitches if you
are so minimal compar compared to that
value so yeah do you have to do it in
every video I don't think so but we'll
sometimes joke if we didn't and then we
look back we're like great got 550,000
views like that would have been nice if
we would have had a call to action in
there a lot of it is it's kind of like
uh dating in relationships in in a way
and and marriage like you could overdo
it like we live in Las Vegas right and
so you could overdo it this happens
maybe a where you like meet someone
you're like hey nice to meet you want to
get married and I suppose that happens
there but that's a little fast for most
people so other than that it's like hey
nice to meet you what's your name should
we go on a date maybe another date
eventually get engaged that's sort of
what I think about in business is sort
of like someone's just kind of by the
outskirts watching some of your videos
um wanting you know I don't want to give
you my contact information but over time
they trust you a little bit more and I
feel like email is getting engaged and
then purchasing a product is like
getting married but that is a journey if
it's healthy typically and it could be a
different pace for other people it may
be that Vegas speed where someone's like
clearly Audrey knows what she's talking
about I just met her I need the Zone
nine thing and they go from like not
knowing you to getting married to buy
your product in literally five minutes
others it takes longer so it's kind of a
dance and sort of a tension to be
managed more than a problem to be
solved yeah that makes sense one other
thing is we'll look at you know Q
sponsored today's video and I put in
zone 9B gardening uh into the daily
ideas do any of these you probably made
all these but maybe not like so uh how
to grow plants in zone 9B Garden the
Paro principle for YouTube that's kind
of weird uh okay so how to grow
vegetables indoor uh Garden like a
pro um how to garden in different zones
how to grow plants in zone NB Garden
these are all pretty basic you've done
all these um I've done them but not that
exact like video title so that's I guess
a question I sort of had was um at what
point because even though I have videos
that have a lot of those points is there
a certain point like in YouTube where
you even as long as you change up
something is it okay to do multiple
videos on essentially the same topic
like cover different Search terms but
change up your video slightly it's a
great question and I think that yes I
think that too many people are afraid of
repeating themselves I think the goal is
actually to say is not to constantly try
to say new things the goal is actually
try to to say the same things in new
ways yeah fresh angle fresh thumbnail
fresh title fresh Nuance fresh season
but to some point you're the expert I
would imagine though that you know the
fundamentals of Zone 9A gardening are
somewhat
consistent but and and here my favorite
example of this actually would be Dave
Ramsey like Dave Ramsey gets a lot of
critique he teaches finances teaches
people to cut up his credit their credit
cards teaches people to get out of debt
he's been doing it for like 30 years
he's been on the radio his YouTube
channel is getting 13 million views a
month his his live stream channel is
getting three million views a month
other
personalities a lot of critics and
cynics will be like Dave's information's
not that good Dave just repeats himself
the same time you're like of course he
does there's only seven baby steps like
it's the same baby there's like nothing
even really that new but what's so funny
about the critics and the cynics is
you're like Dave's built an absolute
Empire and he's transforming millions of
people's lives so while someone on the S
Sidelines could critique and say it's
too simple or you're repeating yourself
or whatever if someone knows you're
repeating yourself you should say thank
you if they comment they are like didn't
you already make this video you should
be like thank you thanks for paying so
much attention because clearly you're a
super fan but the world is so much in
need of good information and there's so
many more people to reach that you want
to be when you have a topic like the
fact like Zone 9B is your search term
you should triple how much you're you're
talking about it but then the key and
like another what I took was I took uh
how to grow plants in zone 9B garden and
I threw it in the AI uh title
recommendations the key could be to just
find like fresh angles like secrets to
thriving in your zone 9 Garden perhaps a
really fresh thumbnail where you think
about like kind of
fresh uh way of of Reinventing how your
thumbnails look a little bit now maybe
you got to be on brand but I was
thinking uh you gotta you know do your
own style but I was looking I was like
to study thumbnails I was looking at
Evan Carmichael's thumbnails and he's
got this kind of like this new people
centered like a Galaxy behind them and
maybe this is you hire this out like you
you find somebody who uh could help you
with thumbnails or whatever but imagine
if you want to talk about it switching
up the look of things if you know
Audrey's in the center slightly
airbrushed and there's a
magical superhero explosion of of
abundant fruit and vegetables around you
says do this you know what I mean it's
like a whole fresh take and then the
title is secrets of thriving in your
Zone 9B Garden um or you know transform
your and so these was also just what
what are we talking about we're talking
about fresh Innovation with kind of the
titles the thumbnails the hook but then
the points and this is really meta
describing what a lot of people that are
super fans of think media they might be
like Sean I swear you've made the same
video a lot of times so be like why
would I why would would I say new things
when the principles that work you know
so how many there's a lot of tips on
YouTube but at some point like I I
shouldn't go be making up new stuff
you're just finding new ways to package
well end on this you know I learned a
big uh St a big lesson from
toothpaste and you know I'll go to
Target and I'll be looking at the
toothpaste aisle and I'm like Crest or
Colgate and I'll look at the label and
it'll say new and improved
first
observation there's actually no way for
something to be new and improved because
if if it's improved it means it's old
because if it's brand new it can't be
improved yet so actually the new and
improved statement is a lie like that's
already so it says new and improved
that's actually impossible but what
actually is it it's marketing secondly
are you actually saying the toothpaste
is new toothpaste hasn't changed in a
hundred years like there's nothing
actually new now admittedly like there's
probably some level of where they need
to have of course Integrity with that
and why is it new it's because they
added charcoal that's a big Trend why is
it new it's because they tweaked one
ingredient why is it new but what do
people UND that that are marketing
products understand they understand that
people love novelty they love new so
when you can take your you can add a
module to your zone 9 now it's new and
improved you're like but it's it
improved and it is is it new well it's
the new version it's the new look but
everybody listening to this that wants
to sell something build something you
want to tap into that because when we're
shopping like we would rather buy the
new Colgate rather than the old Colgate
just because it's something that we're
into we love new stuff new car smell new
shoes we want something that's new so
all of that I don't remember what my
point was but I guess my point is it was
coming back to just finding I think
great content creators
it's it's not enough I think to just
repackage something and have it be stale
and old I think the goal is to actually
get fresh inspiration get some get a new
illustration that that unlocks
understanding what it means to Garden in
zone 9B get a new illustration get a new
way of get a new story get a new way to
frame it get a new way to kind of
package it get a new way to put a
thumbnail on it get a new way to put a
title on it and then do that a thousand
times that's I think where the
Innovative channel that is a gardening
competitor where you will Ex go beyond
them versus what they're doing and at
the end of the day chances are you
versus the other gardening tips person
it's could be pretty similar so the
difference like as far as what the
advices the difference right is going
going to really come down to some of
that online marketing Mastery
understanding maybe some of the language
or creativity or packaging ultimately
we're looking for fresh creativity maybe
in the way that the video is structured
maybe in the way that you try something
a little bit different you're doing the
same thing because there's basic
information that people need need but
you are packaging it in new ways if you
enjoy this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1hour OnDemand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on On Demand right now at think
masterclass.com